Nathan ruff teenager ruff calm and a web
design development company called 1-9
nice game nice blogging Tiger love it
love the plug go ahead main question is
I feel like a lot of small businesses
fail because they refuse to say the
question of the vaynernation or me let's
go good I feel like a lot of small
businesses fail because they refuse to
set what they're not good at for example
I suck at accounting so I have somebody
do accounting for me but I see people
you know they suck at photography but
they're still doing their photography
and it's hurting their brand yeah
they're not accepting that okay your
thoughts on that cool thank you I mean I
you know again as somebody who's been
following my stuff I think we agree on
this right like I'm a big fan of going
all-in and your strengths and
outsourcing or not focusing on your
weaknesses I I think you've got a pegged
right I think the one thing is sometimes
it's obvious right don't get caught in
the obvious meaning it's obvious to you
that you suck at accounting it's kind of
easy right it's math like you probably
also don't wanna or like doing it that's
easy it's the thing that's in the
shadows that's not as obvious there's
something you're doing right now
that a lot of people could do better
than you it's easy when you're an F at
it and you know you need an a but what
about the fact that you might be doing
something right now a tiger or somewhere
else where you're a B at it but you
could afford to have somebody be an a at
it that's where people miss the mistakes
so it takes deep self-awareness you know
I'm not a big believer in like try try
try harder to be better at this thing I
think it's a waste of resources energy
and happiness often now if you get off
on that kind of thing like persevering
knock yourself out roll hey you want to
roll but for me big believer I'm betting
on all your strengths and trying to find
compliments to your weaknesses how would
you like a new one for askgaryvee like
this is cool when they're live they can
follow up how would you bring up like I
you know people have terrible website
doesn't work on a mobile device and
they're just not getting it done just
set that okay they're not gonna get in
walk away or how would you bring up
saying hey you're not really good at now
you're asking me a sales question I
think right like are you saying to reach
out to somebody and say hey we should do
that for you even like from just a help
in providing value like hey you're not
good at this I don't think my companies
are right fit but you're not good at
this I'm just telling you like you know
one of the things that I do tap yeah one
of things I do tactically is just call
people out on it right like I'll reply
to them publicly on Twitter and say hey
you just tweeted wrong
here's that you know my classic like
everybody does this wrong on Twitter you
know I'm not scared to do you know my
route is simple polite polite polite
you're not getting it and I still care
enough which is very rare then I'm gonna
drill you in your face thanks man
oh crap wait subscribe I need
subscriptions because I can't push this
many right hooks in social